elon musk twitter investment could be
bad news for free speech you guys saw
this on whiteboard right yeah just real
quick for your daily dose of irony right
what does that first line say
elon musk just bought a three billion
dollar stake in twitter because when
you're the world's richest human you can
toss billions around like that yeah who
the [ __ ] owns the washington post yeah
uh beth basil
the second richest person in the world
you can never undercut yeah
you've been waiting for this moment
tyler
how many guys know how how the poison
pill works you know the poison pill that
everybody's saying wow they're going to
use the poison pill you've heard of
poison pill but do you know what that
actually means
[Music]
so tom and i were talking about this and
tom made a very good point about the
poison pill here's how poison pill works
so they're sitting there they're saying
like it's a defensive strategy by a
target from to prevent or discourage a
potential hostile takeover by acquiring
a company okay so they want to prevent
musk from taking over
twitter now
twitter stock is 40 some dollars 42
dollars when musk says i'll buy it for
52 dollars it's like a number like that
that you're saying right
so if you
had
a million dollars of twitter stock okay
somebody offered to buy it for 20 higher
today and it's not worth it yeah and
that didn't happen how much did it cost
you two hundred thousand dollars right
so the boards using a poison pill to not
allow musk to bite well let's see what
happens say they succeed okay and they
don't let musk buy it yeah musk is going
to sell his 9.2 percent that he
originally bought from twitter
twitter stock from 42 what is it gonna
drop to
to thirty dollars to twenty five dollars
now watch this
if twitter stock drops from forty two
dollars he offered 52 yeah if it drops
from 42 to 25
do you know what happens to the board
the board gets a massive massive
lawsuits from shareholders do you know
why because every
board's responsibility is who
shareholders
you're responsible for shareholders so
this poison pill is gonna backfire on
twitter again they're playing they're
trying to win the battle which they will
they could and musk is playing the war
exactly he's gonna win the war they have
no clue what they're pretty much doing
is the following here's what they're
doing
they're going to get their asses handed
to them then they're going to get fired
then they're going to save elon musk 20
billion because elon's going to buy it
for
20 billion less than he is today you may
as well take that money today and let
this guy do his thing so this even this
poison pill strategy
is going to be one of the most publicly
embarrassing situations for them so this
is why you trust capitalism and you know
that eventually when you bully people
there's going to be people showing up
that bully the bully and and uh patrick
and all this all this for him to make
the platform someplace where you
everybody can have their opinion because
you guys all know this one side is
winning i don't care what anybody says
they're winning that that canceling and
your your voice cannot be brought up how
many uh things were taken down just
because you know you know fact checkers
and some of the factors like the guy
from uh reuters the owner of reuters
sits on the board of pfizer so you know
what i mean it's isn't that like a
conflict of of interest when you're on
the board of fact-checking [ __ ] that
people like trying to ask questions
about pfizer that's
what i mean it's way it's way too much
if you enjoyed this short clip click
over here to watch another short clip
and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]